ahora veamos si podemos escribir la
fórmula química del compuesto iónico
bromuro de calcio y si se sienten
inspirados los invito a que pause en el
vídeo y traten de resolverlo ustedes
mismos ok lo que se acostumbra a hacer
es que primero escribimos el guión
positivo en este caso el calcio es helio
en positivo y vamos a ver la tabla
periódica para confirmar que el calcio
se ioniza como catión vamos a ver el
calcio se encuentra justo aquí en el
grupo 2 y los elementos del grupo 2
también se conocen como metales alcalino
terreos y sello nizan cuando pierden dos
electrones porque tienen dos electrones
en su última capa electrónica
entonces si el calcio se ioniza nos
queda como co2 más ok y ahora analicemos
la parte del bromuro miren la
terminación uno nos dice que es unión
negativo o mejor dicho un año
y si analizamos el bromo en nuestra
tabla periódica que se encuentra justo
aquí podemos ver que forma parte de los
halogenuros así que le gusta ganar
electrones y tiene sentido que sea el
anión entonces al bromo le gustaría
ganar un electrón para tener 8
electrones en su última capa de
electrónica nuestro anión bromuro se ve
así tiene una carga 1 - ghana un
electrón eso es lo que les gusta a los
elementos de este grupo ahora cuál es la
fórmula recuerden que la clave es que se
forma un compuesto iónico especialmente
uno que tiene bueno aquí no tenemos una
carga neta porque en un compuesto iónico
las cargas se cancelan en este caso la
carga del catión de calcio se cancela
con la carga de la neón bromuro y como
ocurre eso bueno aquí tenemos un 2 más y
aquí sólo tenemos 11 - así que
necesitamos tener 2 bromuro
por cada ión de calcio entonces si por
cada calcio necesitamos dos bromuro si
nos queda así pr2 y ahí está esta es la
fórmula química para el bromuro de
calcio y como supimos que necesitábamos
dos pro muros por cada calcio bueno
porque cuando el calcio se ioniza tiene
una carga dos más porque es un elemento
del grupo 2 y el bromo solo tiene una
carga de menos 1 o mejor dicho
1 - por lo que necesitamos 2 pro muros
por cada ion de calcio